Karen I I love your accent I had I'm
gonna be real with you I thought you
were American you know I'm gonna take
that as a compliment tending to be
American well you do a really good job
thank you you like Christian bailed me
like I had no idea no it's amazing but
I've actually words with a couple Scots
and they all have yes and it's like Alan
that's what anyway he always just to say
these Scottish phrases
oh yeah like never I was like that's not
English like put it like you're pretty
much right like can you have any do you
know any okay should we play a little
game where I say Scottish freeze and you
have to guess what it means
yeah go for it I love this ready for the
first one she's got the height though
what is a pie ball she's up she's high
like what is she doing okay freaking out
ah oh jeez that's how you know that's
not okay then he passed yourself what
that if that's your house
okay it means don't worry what did you
say again don't worry
[Laughter]
I think I said don't worry lost my area
I'm sorry I don't know where oh you're
so kind look I'll just hold it here look
[Applause]
Scotty
unlike star tracker so you know yeah
good I need more power
radiant or something oh sure wait hey
don't you valances people yeah I will
not stop talking until you subscribe to
my youtube channel that's right and I
could talk a lot seriously not gonna
stop yep still here not going anywhere I
see you don't walk away from this